[Music]
so as his forces wage war in ukraine
president vladimir putin has been
leading victory day commemorations in
moscow thousands of soldiers have been
marching through a red square on the day
the nation celebrates the surrender of
nazi germany the soviet troops in 1945
you can see the russian president there
alongside uh one of his russian generals
in red square as the commemorations go
on uh ukraine's president vladimir
lenski is saying that russia's war is
repeating the horrors of the past but
president putin told the crowd at red
square that his troops are fighting for
what he calls the security of their
homeland
you're fighting for our people in
donbass for the safety of our motherland
russia may 9th 1945 will forever be
perpetrated as a triumph of our one
single soviet people of its cohesion and
spiritual might and perilous exploits
both at the front line and at the home
front the victory day is close and
sacred to each one of us
standing by for us in kiev but first
let's go to our correspondent dorset
jabar who's in moscow and at dawson we
were listening to president putin
speaking and interesting perhaps more
because of what he didn't talk about
certainly nick i think uh there was a
lot of expectations here about
what the russian president would say and
whether or not he would talk about what
the people of russia can expect in the
coming days and weeks ahead
but vladimir putin seemingly keeping his
speech very short and within a minute
into that speech he talked about the
justifications for the decision that he
made to send in russian troops into
ukraine on february 24th i think it's
important that he did
link what is happening now in ukraine
and what has happened between russia and
nato as well as the
other western countries to what he
believes to have happened during world
war ii he says that they're
fighting for their
security and that they believe that they
were under threat he even went so far as
to say that he believed that crimea
which russia annexed in 2014 was about
to be attacked by
nato forces and that is why they decided
to take the action that they did he said
that um every life that has been lost in
ukraine is a
sad
loss for the country and he also said
that the families of the victims
of the russian soldiers that have died
in battle in
ukraine will be looked after by the
state he also talked about
how what he did decide to do was a
preemptive rebuff he said that
again he believed that it was the right
decision to do
for russia and this is certainly a very
significant day in this country it's not
only a
victory but it's also something that is
very much part of the culture because
russia of course lost nearly 27 million
people uh during world war ii and
there is not many russians you will find
or speak to that haven't had a personal
connection many people have lost family
members during world war ii and of
course vladimir putin is one of them and
he did say that um the to the soldiers
in red square he said you're fighting
for the same things that your
grandfathers were fighting for so
certainly uh invoking very important
powerful imagery within russian society
but what was missing clearly was what is
coming up what happens next that is
certainly not clear we've also been
seeing footage from sevastopol that is
in crimea of victory day parade that is
ongoing there as well and this is
something of course that is going to
carry out throughout the day and across
russia in all the cities in this country
what is the the kremlin view of progress
that has been made or otherwise during
the the two months or more of this this
so-called special operation
well according to the russian defense
ministry and we just saw the russian
defense minister alongside vladimir
putin in red square walking with him and
speaking to the russian president
according to the defense ministry they
are on track and they are achieving
their goals now
the
phase the first phase of this so-called
special military operation ended the end
of march and now they're into the second
phase which is their focus on um
securing areas in eastern and southern
ukraine and we also heard from vladimir
putin saying that the soldiers
some of them have now just returned from
the battlefield in donbass to take part
in this parade in red square there is a
sense that of course this is now day 75
of this military operation and it
continues but there's no clear outline
about what they are hoping to achieve in
the weeks ahead certainly according to
vladimir putin and his officials they
are on track and they will achieve all
the goals that they set out to do
but what happens after that is not clear
on how long this will take is very
uncertain at this time but it is
important that vladimir putin has the
support of the russian population and
this day is just about that to rally
support behind this cause and it's very
clear that the narrative coming from the
officials here not just today but over
the past few weeks since february has
been to try and link this country's past
with what is happening in the present to
get as much support as possible on
february 24th when vladimir putin
announced that russian soldiers would be
entering ukraine state tv started
broadcasting immediately
images from the war during world war ii
as well as movies that were shown at
that time so there is a sense that this
day is part of the larger narrative that
is unfolding in ukraine
all right daughter we'll leave it there
for the moment thanks very much indeed
uh dr barrow there reporting from moscow
as we watch the
scene in red square president vladimir
putin walking with his military top
brass on the 77th anniversary of the
soviet union's victory over nazi germany
obviously the backdrop to this is the
so-called special operation that's
ongoing in ukraine that's been happening
for more than two months now let's cross
to ukraine to the capital kiev abdul
hamid is life for us there and hoda
we've just been listening to an excerpt
of president putin and what he had to
say
his words would have been carefully
scrutinized there in ukraine what would
have been the view
well certainly i can imagine that
everybody from president zielenski to
the chief of staff will be watching
would have listened very carefully now
there was all sorts of rumors swirling
uh really in the come in the days
leading uh to today
all sort of speculations about what
could president putin say during that
speech and i think it fell uh off the
expectations there was talk that he
might declare an all-out war on uh
ukraine what we saw there from a
ukrainian point of view certainly
a very reserved president putin he did
start his speech um i did feel that it
was reminding us of what he said uh
before the war when he declared this
special operation in
ukraine
but you know at a certain point he is
reminding
the russian people about why victory day
is so important in their history but now
there's a war unfolding here in ukraine
and there is no sign of victory yes the
russians at the end of the day could
outgun and outnumber
the
there you see the air siren going on so
the war is still ongoing and certainly
he hasn't won over the hearts and minds
of the people he said he was
going to protect in the name of which
this war started
this is our report
the real toll of this war for russia
unclaimed body bags stacked in
refrigerated trains
soldiers dead on the front line as
russia claims to rescue the
russian-speaking population living here
ukraine says about 25 000 have lost
their lives so far
but russia puts that number at about
1300.
we were given rare access to the bodies
left behind as russia retreated from the
kiev region
he was an elite paratrooper
this jewelry was found on him allegedly
stolen from ukrainian civilians
ukraine treats the dead enemies better
than how they treated civilians they
will be kept as long as need be the
government will decide because russia
refuses to take them it doesn't want
them each body is a proof of a war crime
so if they refuse to take them ukraine
will bury them at our own cost
the war is in his third month but so far
moscow has no clear victory to show for
it
even in predominantly russian speak in
mariupol where it did enjoy some popular
support in the past
now evgeny sosnovsky says those voices
are gone he just came out of the port
city two days ago
i was cycling past the destroyed theater
building i noticed that they were
clearing the main avenue and the central
square perhaps they were preparing for
this seal called victory parade
but i also could still see the blue and
yellow of the ukrainian flag and vendors
are refusing to sell goods in ruble only
ukrainian currency
evgeny has documented life under
occupation as much as he could without
getting detected by soldiers
hardly the image of a liberated people
the kremlin want to portray
after failing to take keefe russia has
concentrated its air power on destroying
ukraine's infrastructure in what it
called a special military operation but
so far more than 3 000 civilians have
lost their lives and the human cost for
both sides is rising by the day
olga is among the millions displaced by
the conflict she's also just made it to
safety with her two young children and
mother
before their arrival life was good we
had a beautiful city parks everyone had
life plans work freedom of choice of
language freedom of movement freedom of
thoughts we lived freely then russia
came to rescue us they liberated us from
our houses our jobs some of their lives
some of their legs or arms that's the
liberation
olga has now switched to the ukrainian
language with her children
while russia celebrates its victory
against nazi germany at the end of world
war ii
it is now embattled in a war that didn't
go as expected
that's a fascinating report it's
interesting isn't it this kind of tragic
irony that both ukrainian and russian
soldiers fought
alongside each other in the war that
victory day commemorates
yes absolutely and actually you hear
that
especially when you speak to elderly
people who also have uh you know family
history when it comes to world war ii uh
they were they are quite flabbergasted
especially in the east of the country
where you heard these that generation
kind of always defending russia and they
were accused of being pro-russian even
until the eve of the when the war
started
well that has changed maybe the
pro-russian voices are silent at the
moment uh because of the overwhelming
anger among ukrainians but i think one
of the main uh
points one of them that came out of this
war is this new solidarity among
ukrainians whether in the west or the
east of the country that was maybe
lacking in the days uh leading uh to the
war so when it comes to hearts and minds
i would say that at the moment russia is
on uh losing ground now also militarily
um there is no clear victory so far the
as the the ukrainian forces the azov
regiment that is holed up in that steel
works uh is still holding up a fight
even though on their last legs according
uh to them and then everywhere else
wherever russia arrives there's more
that's unfolding in the east or in the
south of the country wherever russia
arrives it arrives after a considerable
amount of destruction people losing
their homes people losing their villages
schools attacked all sorts of targets
being hit
so all of that is coming at a huge cost
for russia which is also losing uh its
own people on the battlefield and
according to the ukrainians about 25 000
soldiers russian puts that number much
lower around 13 to 1500 but it's
certainly a huge cost and at the moment
when you're here on the ground you can't
see where it's gonna end russia wants to
take territory wants to impose its own
people on that territory but it will
come at an extremely high cost for both
countries
thanks very much indeed for that abdul
hamad reporting there from kiev
in ukraine while we look at pictures
from moscow where we've been following
the 77th anniversary of the soviet
union's victory over nazi germany
victory day being commemorated we've
watched vladimir putin and heard from
vladimir putin too and just seen him uh
at the alexander garden of the kremlin
commemorating falling soldiers
laying a wreath down at the
unknown soldier's grave there
let's bring in sergey markov who is also
in moscow director of the institute of
political studies there and a former
public spokesman for president putin
joins us now from moscow
welcome to the show sergey markov it's
interesting listening wasn't it to
vladimir putin speaking because he laid
out his reasoning for the special
operation but he didn't throw it forward
at all no mention of
you know what the objectives are and
where this might all end
yes
of course the main
topic of this uh speech of have been put
in which been very much expected from
our audience uh has been devoted to the
special military operation on
identification of ukraine
and uh
vladimir putin uh
didn't claim mobilization and vladimir
putin didn't claim any uh
situational war against ukraine which
some of the experts and politicians
expected and the same time main says
vladimir putin that this war had been
inevitable because united states and
nato which is regarded as main
russian enemies now
they are fully denied russian concern
about security and they created a very
uh military brutal and aggressive regime
on the ukrainian territory which first
of all include neo-nazis and but their
rights his issue was by the way is
just a new word in english
language
why do you think why do you think the
president didn't throw uh this forward
to lay out more about the objectives of
russia and ukraine is it because he
would find it hard to explain to
russians
why they actually need to go to fight
and die in a war that russia is
allegedly winning
it's not uh so
first of all uh uh vladimir putin is a
former secret agent of russian and
terror of the residence service soviet
under servants kgb
and uh he
uh doing uh politics main decision in
his politics
in the style of
special admiration
keeping
all uh goals as seeker and according to
the
ancient ancient chinese theory or war
if your enemy doesn't know what is your
real uh
uh goals uh aims it's uh your part of
your benefits so it's mostly important
okay
mr putin said as you've just been
talking about the russia's hand was
forced by the the posturing and the
threatening behavior of the west but in
fact
isn't it the case that this so-called
special operation has coalesced the eu
it's coalesced nato and the united
states and indeed nato now looks set to
expand rather than contract because of
this it's actually had the opposite
effect
uh
in russia
it's
ukrainian army doesn't exist as army of
ukrainian people and ukrainian people
doesn't exist on president vladimir
zelinsky because he just pocket on the
head of the united states and great
britain and same time ukrainian army
fully devoted to the american and
british
military advices and
political uh political advices so it's
proxy army of the united states and
great britain and uh nato it's not
ukrainian army
you said on march the third that this
war will end and much less of two months
ago more than two months ago this war
will end after russia liberates
two-thirds of ukrainian territory from
the neo-nazi repressive regime and a new
government
will be formed that was march a third
your words it hasn't gone the way you
anticipated two months ago has it
uh it's absolutely clear that just
russian strategy have been not
successful russian territory was uh
to to come to the biggest city escape
when
and then
um expectedly uh ukrainian authorities
will leave those cities and will be
working off power will be taken by a
pro-russian politician but it's not
appeared to be also ukrainian army
appear to be which is proxima of the
united states uh much more strong
than uh russian uh analysis uh expected
so this war appeared to be much more
difficult and bloody as then
we expected now
we expected that
this will be
battle for dunbas will continue uh
probably to the until the
middle of
summer and then uh based on the result
of this battle on dambass
new political decisions
will be made but
now those
predictions which is uh reflected that
plans of russian authorities which i get
uh
appear to be
not valid now we should think about new
uh
analysis of or what is uh will happening
honestly
we'll have to leave it there i'm sorry
we've just run out of time do you
appreciate your perspective on this
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on al jazeera thank you